tell me that doesn't feel like a [ __ ]
now I know how the poor people of
Pompeii felt like
wait
um
bamboo she got me there like the a
Express train
this is First Impressions
wow
good are you ready I'm so ready
I'm going to bed what either you come
out with another
let me start again you know what I'm
doing anyway don't you
what what surely go I'm going to bed
before either of you come up with
another clever idea to get us killed or
Worse expelled
um
yes
I've been waiting my whole life
I can't believe that was my first one
strategically no
immediately no immediately no
immediately all right ready
just started really happy yeah
just like I'm really good like being
stuck doing sports and stuff Sports and
stuff yeah I'm married I really know how
to work oh my God sorry is this a
footballer yes is that is it um
[Laughter]
I know who you're talking about I don't
know his name he
um sorry this is we need to keep the
pace up
foreign
[Music]
um
you will be
tiny little creatures in film that you
know Emily no no
you know what part of one is you know
what a Padawan is no the force uh Star
Wars yeah oh uh the little green thing
absolutely tragic yeah have you ever
seen Star Wars it was yoga okay I'm
gonna do um no because the thing is in
some
no I'm I mean of course I'm an icon
I'm an artist
I'm a singer
this is excellent I don't know who it is
no no I don't and then
um
uh she said
um
do it oh oh oh
um yes Adele yeah
oh I hope you know these references
um
tell me that doesn't feel like a [ __ ]
hahaha
now I know how the poor people of
Pompeii felt like
wait
um
um
she got me there like the air express
train
any bells yes yes
this is happening to me please please
give me an answer please just do a bit
more mustache
[Applause]
very good one
I'm just gonna do this
so like trousers up here
right and then like Schoolboy haircut
right I'm goes I think
[Music]
and it's Simon Cowell yoga
oh
mustache driving Luigi the other one
Mario
Luigi yeah let me do your side
all along
[Music]
um
microwave
you make me want a hot dog real bad I'm
Jennifer Coolidge
no I feel like
um
thank you so much this we've we've also
retire okay not through Choice thank you
for letting me do a Hermione Granger
impression
on your microphone I won
did you actually win yeah
[Applause]
you're my hero you're the hero of my
dreams all right good thank you
it's okay what the [ __ ] just happened
yeah we gotta leave it in oh wow hello
how are you
um
is it De Niro what the